What's it mean to do politics in this country these days? Consider the story of a man named Jack Robinson. One day this March, he held a press conference to announce that he was going to start gathering signatures to get on the ballot to run for senate in Massachusetts against Teddy Kennedy. He had never run for political office before.
如今在这个国家搞政治意味着什么？来看看杰克·罗宾逊（Jack Robinson）的故事。今年3月的一天，他召开新闻发布会，宣布将开始收集签名，以争取马萨诸塞州参议员的竞选资格，挑战泰迪·肯尼迪（Teddy Kennedy）。他此前从未竞选过任何政治职位。
And then literally within 24 hours of putting our name forward, we were hit with a withering attack, literally within the first day of even announcing the campaign. I was at Republican State Committee headquarters having interviews with the press. And sitting down with one of the reporters, the reporter asked me after I said why I'm running, by the way, have you ever been arrested for drunk driving? And I said, yes. No one would know about that because we sealed the case file, since I had been found not guilty and I'd passed the Breathalyzer test. I was very forthright and then gave the details. But that was the beginning of it. And then it just didn't stop. Then, have you ever had a restraining order ever taken against you and then this and then that and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
“在我们提交申请后的24小时内，甚至就在宣布竞选活动的头一天，我们就遭到了毁灭性的攻击。当时我正在共和党州委员会总部接受媒体采访。在与一位记者交谈时，我刚说完参选理由，他便问我：‘顺便问一下，你有没有因为酒驾被捕过？’我说：‘有。’本来没人会知道这件事，因为我们已经封存了案件档案，况且我当时被判无罪，并且通过了酒精呼气测试。我非常坦诚地提供了细节。但这只是个开始。之后攻击就没停过。接着是：‘有没有人对你申请过限制令？’然后又是这个那个，巴拉巴拉一大堆。”
The plan was to announce the campaign and, perhaps this was political naivete on my part, maybe get a week or so of general publicity about what we stand for, who are we. Little did I know that within a day of announcing the campaign, no one would care about any of that stuff, who I am or what I stand for, but what's in my past.
“原本的计划是宣布竞选，也许是我政治天真了，我以为能争取到一周左右的宣传时间，让大家了解我们的主张和身份。但我没想到，宣布竞选还不到一天，就没人关心那些了，大家关心的不是我是谁或我主张什么，而是我的过去。”
And so Jack Robinson decided to take action. He issued a long public statement that is simply one of the most remarkable documents of current political life in this country. He called it "The Robinson Report" and posted it on the Internet for anybody to read. It outlines, in matter of fact prose and a disturbing level of detail, everything he thinks he's ever done wrong: an unpaid speeding ticket from the 1980s, an illegal martial arts implement that a police officer found in his pocket when he was a graduate student, his failure to pass the bar exam three times, a plagiarism case against him, a restraining order that a woman put against him, a variety of business lawsuits.
于是，杰克·罗宾逊决定采取行动。他发表了一份冗长的公开声明，这堪称我国当代政治生活中最引人注目的文件之一。他将其命名为《罗宾逊报告》（The Robinson Report），并发布在互联网上供人查阅。报告以客观的文字和令人不安的详尽程度，列举了他认为自己做过的所有错事：20世纪80年代一张未缴的超速罚单、他在读研时被警察发现的一件非法武术器材、三次律师资格考试不及格、一起针对他的剽窃诉讼、一名女子对他申请的限制令，以及各种商业纠纷。
"By making this information public early in the campaign," he wrote, "I hope to have offered my fellow citizens a full and fair description of my personal background in a manner which allows them to decide whether I am capable of representing them in a position of public trust, confidence, and honor."
“通过在竞选初期公开这些信息，”他写道，“我希望向同胞们完整、公正地描述我的个人背景，让他们能够判断我是否有能力代表他们履行公职，肩负公众的信任、信心和荣誉。”
I've been told I've been the first person in American political history to drop a dime on himself. But I think the citizens will have to decide over the foreseeable future as to how much they want to know about people. I've done nothing wrong. I've committed no crimes. I've got no record. At the end of the day, people don't care about my drunk driving arrest 15 years ago any more than they care about Chappaquiddick 30 years ago.
“有人告诉我，我是美国政治史上第一个把自己‘抖出来’的人。但我认为，未来民众将不得不决定他们到底想了解一个人到什么程度。我没做错任何事。我没犯过罪。我没有犯罪记录。说到底，人们并不关心我15年前的酒驾被捕，就像他们不关心30年前的查帕奎迪克事件一样。”
Jack Robinson mentioned Chappaquiddick and what he called "Ted Kennedy's foibles," four times in the hour that I spent with him, each time declaring they should not be part of any campaign. Sort of nasty. But what exactly is a man to do? This is the state of politics in America.
在我与杰克·罗宾逊相处的一小时里，他四次提到查帕奎迪克事件以及他所说的“泰德·肯尼迪的怪癖”，每次都声称这些不应该成为竞选的一部分。听起来确实有点恶毒。但一个人到底该怎么做呢？这就是美国的政治现状。
And as we head into another season of presidential campaigning, Al Gore is already pounding on George Bush. And George Bush made clear in the primaries that went threatened, he'll get as nasty as he has to. The next few months of our political lives are going to be ugly, just ugly.
随着我们进入又一个总统竞选季，阿尔·戈尔（Al Gore）已经开始攻击乔治·布什（George Bush）。而乔治·布什在初选中也明确表示，一旦受到威胁，他会不择手段地进行反击。未来几个月的政治生活将变得丑陋，极其丑陋。
So in preparation for all the mud, we asked today, what are we to think of all this? What are we to make of what our culture has become? From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, to shed light on the current situation, true stories of character assassination-- political and nonpolitical.
因此，为了应对这些泥浆战，我们今天想问：我们该如何看待这一切？我们该如何看待我们的文化变成了什么样？这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台（PRI）的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天的节目将揭示当前的局势，讲述政治与非政治领域中真正的“人格暗杀”故事。
Our program today in five acts. Act One, "Those Who Ignore History are Condemned to Repeat It-- but Those Who Pay Attention to History are Also Condemned to Repeat It." Act Two, "Sonny Takes a Fall," in which David Foster Wallace reports on a turning point in the primary campaign of John McCain. John McCain's last moment as a serious contender-- the moment when his opponent started attacking and he had to decide how to handle it, and how he decided-- wrong. Act Three, "When Slime is Good." A former political consultant explains why it is that he tried to bait his opponent into attacking-- sometimes. Act Four, "Who are you Going to Call?" A conversation with one of the people that you'll hire if you're attacked. Act Five, "When Attacks Really Count," a look at character assassination when it occurs in a far more devastating arena than politics, I'm talking about junior high school. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为五幕。第一幕，“忘记历史的人注定重蹈覆辙——但关注历史的人也注定重蹈覆辙”。第二幕，“桑尼跌倒了”（Sonny Takes a Fall），大卫·福斯特·华莱士（David Foster Wallace）报道约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）初选中的转折点。约翰·麦凯恩作为有力竞争者的最后时刻——那是他的对手开始攻击他，他必须决定如何应对的时刻，以及他如何决定——做出了错误的决定。第三幕，“当污蔑有益时”。一位前政治顾问解释了他为何有时试图诱使对手发起攻击。第四幕，“你该打给谁？”与你受攻击时会聘请的人进行的一场对话。第五幕，“当攻击真正起作用时”，探讨发生在比政治更具破坏性的竞技场——初中里的“人格暗杀”。请留在我们身边。
Act One, "Those Who Ignore History are Condemned to Repeat It." Ask most historians about dirty political attacks and they will tell you that they go back to the very beginning of our nation, Thomas Jefferson. Thomas Jefferson funded an opposition newspaper to trash President George Washington while Jefferson was actually part of Washington's administration. For most of the next 200 years, politicians routinely accused each other of being philanderers, of having illegitimate children, of being atheists. The only things that are different now, says historian Richard Norton Smith, are that first, none of us remember that because none of us knows anything about history. And second, because of television and the other electronic media. We see every reaction flash over these guys' faces, which gives it all a certain emotional power.
第一幕，“忘记历史的人注定重蹈覆辙”。问问大多数历史学家关于肮脏的政治攻击，他们会告诉你，这可以追溯到我们国家的开端——托马斯·杰斐逊（Thomas Jefferson）。杰斐逊在身为华盛顿政府成员时，竟资助反对派报纸诋毁乔治·华盛顿总统。在接下来的200年里，政客们习惯性地指责对方通奸、有私生子、是无神论者。历史学家理查德·诺顿·史密斯（Richard Norton Smith）认为，现在唯一不同的是，第一，我们都不记得了，因为我们对历史一无所知；第二，是因为电视和其他电子媒体的存在。我们能看到这些人在镜头前的一举一动，这赋予了这一切某种情感冲击力。
I mean, it's all in close up. It's much more intimate-- politics is much more intimate today. One hundred years ago, or even the early part of the 20th century, presidents were essentially remote figures. We saw them in newspapers. We didn't see them 24 hours a day. They didn't come into our living rooms. They weren't, in effect, an extended member of the family or a member of the extended family. There's an intimacy about the modern presidency.
“我的意思是，这一切都是特写。它更亲密——今天的政治更亲密。一百年前，甚至20世纪初，总统本质上是遥不可及的人物。我们在报纸上看到他们。我们不会24小时看着他们。他们不会走进我们的客厅。实际上，他们不是家庭的一员或大家庭的一员。现代总统制有一种亲密感。”
In fact, that intimacy extends to all politics at every level. For example, what could be more intimate than this phone call which made statewide news in Massachusetts? Even the car guys played it on their program on NPR. Senatorial candidate Jack Robinson was on his cell phone talking to reporter Toni Randolph from Public Radio station WBUR. She was recording an interview asking about that day's news, that Governor Paul Cellucci had dropped his support for Robinson.
事实上，这种亲密感延伸到了各级政治中。例如，还有什么比这个在马萨诸塞州引起全州轰动的电话更亲密呢？甚至连NPR的车评节目都播出了这个电话。参议员候选人杰克·罗宾逊正在用手机与WBUR公共广播电台的记者托妮·兰道夫（Toni Randolph）交谈。她当时正在录制一段采访，询问关于保罗·塞卢奇（Paul Cellucci）州长撤回对罗宾逊支持的当天新闻。
Basically, what you have is a Republican governor abdicating the United States senate campaign to Senator Kennedy just because the Governor doesn't think that there could be. I just got in an accident. Sorry about that. Are you still there?
“基本上，你所看到的是一位共和党州长因为认为不可能获胜，就将参议院竞选拱手让给了肯尼迪参议员。我刚才出了车祸。抱歉。你还在那儿吗？”
I'm still here. Are you-- you got into an accident?
“我还在。你——你出车祸了？”
Well, somebody just hit me but I'm OK. Unfortunately, the other guy skidded across the highway here. But at any rate, boy, everything's happening to me. Cellucci's withdrawing his support and now people are sledding across the highway at me. But I'm OK. Looks like the other guy is too.
“嗯，有人撞了我，但我没事。不幸的是，那个人在高速公路上打滑了。不管怎样，天哪，所有事都发生在我身上。塞卢奇撤回了支持，现在又有人滑到我车上。但我没事。看起来那个人也没事。”
You sure you're OK?
“你确定你没事？”
Yes, I am. I'm fine.
“是的，我很好。”
OK. I don't know-- I'm in new territory here.
“好吧。我不知道——我这还是第一次遇到这种情况。”
Yeah, I know. I think we'll have to stop the interview. But you got what you need. Sorry about that.
“是的，我知道。我想我们得停止采访了。但你已经得到你需要的东西了。抱歉。”
With the car accident, the stream of attack stories, the sheer oddness of putting out "The Robinson Report," detailing his own past-- at some point, a kind of pile-on mentality kicked in with the press and Jackie Robinson. And at this point, the press and other politicians don't seem to take him very seriously. But when another WBUR reporter, Sean Cole, spent a day watching Robinson meet Republican voters, they were all so relieved that anybody would run against Kennedy, they embraced him. So it's hard to say if revealing all this about himself has helped or hurt him.
伴随着车祸、一连串的攻击性报道，以及发布《罗宾逊报告》这一极其怪异的行为，详述自己的过去——在某种程度上，媒体和杰克·罗宾逊之间产生了一种“群起而攻之”的心态。此时，媒体和其他政客似乎并不把他当回事。但当另一位WBUR记者肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）花了一天时间观察罗宾逊与共和党选民接触时，选民们却因有人愿意挑战肯尼迪而感到如释重负，并接受了他。所以，很难说披露这些关于自己的事情到底对他是有利还是有弊。
Do you feel like it's fair that a person should have to say this much about themselves to get an office?
“你觉得一个人为了竞选公职而被迫说出这么多关于自己的事，这公平吗？”
I don't know. It's difficult for me to answer that intellectually honestly. Whether it's fair or not really is not for me to determine. The people of Massachusetts will have to determine that.
“我不知道。要在理智上诚实地回答这个问题对我来说很难。是否公平真的不由我来决定。马萨诸塞州的人民必须做出决定。”
But what do you think, personally?
“那你个人怎么看？”
I don't know. I mean, I've done it.
“我不知道。我的意思是，我已经做了。”
But personally, do you feel that it's fair? Does it feel right that you should have to do something like this to run for office?
“但就个人而言，你觉得这公平吗？为了竞选公职而不得不做这样的事，感觉对吗？”
No, it's definitely not right in my opinion. Clearly, I can answer that today. That's not how we should be picking candidates, as to who's got the strongest hide to disclose everything in their personal background that could possible be used against him.
“不，在我看来绝对不对。我可以明确回答。我们不应该通过这种方式来挑选候选人，即看谁的脸皮最厚，能把自己背景中所有可能被利用的丑事都公开出来。”
There's this notion you hear sometimes that the viciousness of modern politics keeps good people from running for office. But sometimes the politics of attack simply hastens the political demise of a candidate whose prospects weren't so great from the start. Meeting Jack Robinson, you wonder about his seriousness. In his last official filing with the federal election commission, his campaign war chest had $613 in it as compared with his opponent's $3.7 million. He has yet to articulate any policy positions he seems truly impassioned about. And when I visited his campaign headquarters, there were no signs in the windows, no campaign posters out front, nothing that would let anybody know that anybody was running for anything.
你有时会听到这样一种说法：现代政治的残酷让好人不敢参选。但有时，攻击性的政治只会加速那些本来就前景堪忧的候选人的政治灭亡。在见到杰克·罗宾逊后，你会怀疑他的认真程度。在他向联邦选举委员会提交的最后一份正式文件中，他的竞选资金只有613美元，而他的对手有370万美元。他还没能阐明任何让他真正充满激情的政策立场。当我参观他的竞选总部时，窗户上没有标语，门外没有竞选海报，没有任何迹象表明有人在参选任何职位。
Act Two. "Sonny Takes a Fall."
第二幕，“桑尼跌倒了”。
It turns out that if both sides in a political fight start throwing mud at each other, contrary to what you might think, it can definitely benefit one side more than the other. In a sense, this is the scenario that decided this year's republican nomination for president. David Foster Wallace happened to be reporting on the South Carolina primaries on the campaign of John McCain, when he got a chance to see this happen firsthand.
事实证明，如果政治斗争中的双方都开始互相泼脏水，与你可能认为的相反，这绝对可能对某一方更有利。从某种意义上说，这就是决定今年共和党总统提名的情境。大卫·福斯特·华莱士当时正在报道南卡罗来纳州初选中约翰·麦凯恩的竞选活动，他亲眼见证了这一切的发生。
Even the network techs, who are practically zen masters at waiting around and killing time, are bored out of their minds today. The way the techs handle deep boredom is to become extremely sluggish and torpid. So that lined up on the makeshift ottoman, they look like an exhibit of lizards whose rock isn't hot enough. Nobody reads. Pulse rates are maybe about 40. The ABC cameraman lets his eyes almost close and naps in an un-restful way. The CBS and CNN techs who like cards today are not even bothering to play cards but are instead describing memorable card games they've been in in the past.
甚至连那些在等待中消磨时间的禅师级网络技术人员，今天也都感到极度无聊。技术人员应对极度无聊的方式是变得极其迟钝。他们排在临时的脚凳上，看起来就像是一群石头不够热的蜥蜴展览。没人读书。脉搏大概只有40。ABC的摄像师让眼睛半闭，睡得很不安稳。CBS和CNN的技术人员今天喜欢玩牌，但甚至懒得去玩，而是在描述过去玩过的令人难忘的牌局。
Outside the riverfront hotel's side door, where it's so cold and windy you have to smoke with mittens on, Jim C. and his partner, Frank C.-- no relation-- engage in some off-the-record discourse about the 12 monkeys. This is the tech's private code name for the most elite and least popular pencils in the McCain press corps.
在河畔酒店的侧门外，那里寒风刺骨，得戴着连指手套才能抽烟，吉姆·C和他的搭档弗兰克·C（无亲属关系）正在就“12只猴子”进行非正式交谈。这是技术人员给麦凯恩新闻团中最精英、最不受欢迎的记者们起的私人代号。
The 12 monkeys are a dozen marquis journalists and political analysis guys from the really important papers and weeklies and new services, and tend to be so totally identical in dress and demeanor as to be almost literally surreal. 12 immaculate and wrinkle free, navy blue blazers, half-windsored ties, pleated chinos, Oxford cloth shirts that even when the jackets come off stay 100% buttoned at collar and sleeves, Cole Haan loafers, and tortoise shell specs they love to take off and nibble the arm of. Plus always a uniform self-seriousness that reminds you of every over-achieving dweeb you ever wanted to kick the ass of in school.
“12只猴子”是来自重要报纸、周刊和新闻社的十几位著名记者和政治分析员，他们的穿着和举止极其一致，简直到了超现实的地步。12件一尘不染、没有褶皱的海军蓝西装外套，温莎领带，百褶卡其裤，牛津布衬衫——即使脱下外套也保持衣领和袖口扣得严严实实，Cole Haan乐福鞋，还有他们喜欢摘下来啃镜腿的玳瑁眼镜。再加上总是千篇一律的自我重要感，让你想起学校里每个你想踢屁股的“优等生”。
The techs avoid and try to pretty much ignore the 12 monkeys, who in turn treat the techs the way someone in an executive washroom treats the attendant. On return from the smoke break, we pass through a huge, empty, lobby-like space. It takes a long time to traverse this area, 100 yards of nothing but flagstone walls and plaques with the sad, pretentious names of the riverfront hotel's banquet halls and conference rooms-- the Oak Room, the Windsor Room.
技术人员避开并尽量无视“12只猴子”，而后者对待技术人员的方式就像行政洗手间里的人对待服务员一样。烟后，我们穿过一个巨大的、空旷的大厅。穿过这个区域需要很长时间，100码长的石墙上挂着河畔酒店宴会厅和会议室那些悲伤、浮夸的名字——橡木厅、温莎厅。
But now out here are also half a dozen different members of the campaign press, each 50 feet away from any of the others for privacy and all walking in idle little counterclockwise circles with a cellphone to their ear. These little orbits are the cellular waltz, which is probably the digital equivalent of doodling or picking at yourself as you talk on a regular landline. There's something oddly lovely about the waltz's different circles here, which are of various diameters and stride lengths and rates of rotation, but are all identically counterclockwise and telephonic.
但现在这里还有半打竞选新闻团成员，每个人为了隐私都保持50英尺的距离，都在百无聊赖地逆时针绕小圈走，耳朵上贴着手机。这些小轨道是“蜂窝华尔兹”，这可能是在手机上交谈时乱涂乱画或抠手指的数字等价物。这些华尔兹中不同圆圈的移动有种奇异的可爱之处，它们的直径、步幅和旋转速度各不相同，但轨迹却惊人地一致，都是逆时针且充满电磁感。
We three slow down a bit to watch. You couldn't not. From above, like if there were a mezzanine, the waltzes would look like the cogs of some strange, diffused machine. Frank C. says he can tell by their faces something's up. Jim C. says what's interesting is that media south of the Equator do the exact same cellular waltz, but that down there all their circles are reversed.
我们三人放慢脚步观看。你不可能不看。从上方看，如果有一个夹层，这些华尔兹看起来就像某种奇怪、弥散机器的齿轮。弗兰克·C说他能从他们的脸上看出有事情要发生。吉姆·C说有趣的是，赤道以南的媒体也跳着完全一样的“蜂窝华尔兹”，但在那里，他们所有的圆圈都是反向的。
And it turns out, Frank C. was right as usual, that the reason press are dashing out and waltzing urgently in the lobby is that word has apparently started to spread that Mr. Mike Murphy of the McCain 2000 high command is coming down to do a surprise, impromptu press avail regarding a fresh, two-page press release still slightly warm from the Xerox, which two press liaisons are passing out even now, and of which the first page has, in bold caps, "Bush campaign caught red-handed with negative ads-- unethical push polling."
事实证明，弗兰克·C像往常一样正确，记者们在大厅里匆忙奔走和跳华尔兹的原因是，有消息传出，麦凯恩2000竞选指挥部的迈克·墨菲（Mike Murphy）先生将下来进行一次突发的、即兴的新闻发布会，内容是关于一份新鲜出炉的两页新闻稿——复印件还没凉透，两名新闻联络员甚至还在发放，第一页上用加粗大写字母写着：“布什竞选团队当场被抓，负面广告——不道德的民意陷阱（push polling）”。
This document is unusual not only because McCain 2000's press releases are normally studies in bland irrelevance-- "McCain to continue campaigning in Michigan today," "McCain has two helpings of potato salad at South Carolina VFW picnic." But also because no less a personage than Mr. Mike Murphy has indeed now just come down to spin this abrupt change of tone in the campaign's rhetoric.
这份文件之所以不寻常，不仅因为麦凯恩2000的新闻稿通常是平淡无奇的研究——“麦凯恩今天在密歇根州继续竞选”、“麦凯恩在南卡罗来纳州退伍军人野餐会上吃了两份土豆沙拉”，还因为迈克·墨菲先生本人确实刚刚下来，要为竞选修辞中这一突然的基调转变进行“公关”。
Murphy, who is only 37 but seems older, is the McCain campaign's senior strategist, a professional political consultant who's already had 18 winning senate and gubernatorial campaigns. He's a short, bottom-heavy man, pale in a kind of yeasty way, with baby-fine red hair on a large head and sleepy, turtle eyes behind the same sort of intentionally nerdy horn-rims that a lot of musicians and college kids now wear.
墨菲年仅37岁，但看起来更老。他是麦凯恩竞选团队的资深战略家，一位专业的政治顾问，已经有18次获胜的参议院和州长竞选经历。他是一个矮个子，重心靠下，脸色带着某种发酵般的苍白，大头上长着婴儿般细软的红发，在那类很多音乐家和大学生现在戴的刻意书呆子气的角质框眼镜后，有一双困倦的、像乌龟一样的眼睛。
Among political pros, Murphy has the reputation of being, one, smart and funny as hell, and two, a real attack dog working for clients like Oliver North, New Jersey's Christine Todd Whitman, and Michigan's own John Engler in campaigns that were absolute operas of nastiness. He's leaning back against the file-and-feed room's wall and is surrounded in 180 degree arc by the 12 monkeys, all of whom have steno notebooks or tiny professional tape recorders out and keep clearing their throats and pushing their glasses up with excitement.
在政治专业人士中，墨菲以聪明、风趣和是真正的“攻击犬”而闻名，他曾为奥利弗·诺斯（Oliver North）、新泽西州的克里斯汀·托德·惠特曼（Christine Todd Whitman）和密歇根州的约翰·恩格勒（John Engler）等客户工作，那些竞选绝对是充满恶意的歌剧。他靠在收发室的墙上，被180度弧形的“12只猴子”包围，他们都拿着速记本或小型专业录音机，不断清嗓子，兴奋地推着眼镜。
Murphy says he's, quote, "Just swung by to provide the press corps with some context on the strident press release and to give the corps advanced notice that the McCain campaign is also preparing a special response ad which will start airing in South Carolina tomorrow." Murphy uses the words "response" or "response ad" nine times in two minutes. And when one of the monkeys interrupts to ask whether it'd be fair to characterize this new ad as negative, Murphy gives him a long styptic look and spells out very slowly, R-E-S-P-O-N-S-E.
墨菲说他，“只是顺便过来为新闻团提供一些关于激进新闻稿的背景，并提前通知新闻团，麦凯恩竞选团队也正在准备一份特别的响应广告，明天开始在南卡罗来纳州播出。”墨菲在两分钟内使用了9次“响应”或“响应广告”。当其中一只“猴子”打断他，询问将这则新广告描述为负面是否公平，墨菲给了他一个漫长的审视眼神，并非常缓慢地拼写道：“R-E-S-P-O-N-S-E”。
He says that the press release and new ad reflect the McCain 2000 campaign's decision, after much agonizing, to respond to what he says is G. W. Bush's welshing on the two candidates' public handshake agreement in January to run a bilaterally positive campaign. For the past five days, mostly in New York and South Carolina, the shrub has apparently been running ads that characterize McCain's policy proposals in what Murphy terms a, "Willfully distorting way." Plus there's the push polling, a practice which is regarded as the absolute bottom feeder of sleazy campaign tactics.
他说，新闻稿和新广告反映了麦凯恩2000竞选团队在经历多次痛苦挣扎后，决定回应他所说的乔治·W·布什对1月份两位候选人公开握手协议的违背，即进行双向积极竞选。过去五天里，主要在纽约和南卡罗来纳州，布什显然一直在投放广告，用墨菲的话说，“以故意扭曲的方式”描述麦凯恩的政策建议。此外还有“民意陷阱”，这被认为是肮脏竞选策略的绝对底层。
But the worst, the most obviously unacceptable, Murphy emphasizes, was the shrub standing up at a podium in South Carolina a couple days ago with a wild-eyed and apparently notorious fringe veteran who publicly accused McCain of, quote, "Abandoning his fellow veterans after returning from Vietnam," which Murphy says, even without going into McCain's well-documented personal bio and heroic legislative efforts on behalf of vets for nearly 20 years, is just so clearly over the line of even minimal personal decency and honor, that it pretty much necessitates some sort of response.
但墨菲强调，最糟糕、最明显不可接受的是，布什几天前在南卡罗来纳州的讲台上，与一位眼神狂野且显然臭名昭著的边缘退伍军人站在一起，此人公开指责麦凯恩“从越南归来后抛弃了战友”。墨菲说，即使不谈麦凯恩有据可查的个人简历和他近20年来为退伍军人所做的英雄般的立法努力，这也显然越过了最低限度的个人体面和荣誉的界限，几乎有必要做出某种回应。
The 12 monkeys, who are old pros at this sort of exchange, keep trying to steer Murphy away from what the shrub's done and get him to give a quotable explanation of why McCain himself has decided to run this response ad, a transcript of which the harried press liaisons are now distributing from a fresh copier box, and which reads, in part, "I guess it was bound to happen. Governor Bush's campaign is getting desperate with a negative ad about me. His ad twists the truth like Clinton. We're all pretty tired of that."
“12只猴子”这类交换意见的老手，不断试图引导墨菲离开布什所做的事情，让他给出一个可引用的解释，说明为什么麦凯恩本人决定投放这则响应广告。疲惫的新闻联络员正在分发广告副本，部分内容写道：“我想这是注定的。布什州长的竞选团队正因针对我的负面广告而变得绝望。他的广告像克林顿一样扭曲事实。我们都对此感到厌烦。”
The 12 monkeys now point out that, in particular, the "Twist the truth like Clinton," bit seems negative indeed, since in the year 2000, comparing the GOP candidate to Bill Clinton was roughly equivalent to claiming that he wears ladies' underwear while presiding over satanic masses.
“12只猴子”现在指出，特别是“像克林顿一样扭曲事实”这一点确实非常负面，因为在2000年，将共和党候选人比作比尔·克林顿（Bill Clinton），大致等同于声称他在主持撒旦弥撒时穿着女士内衣。
While checking their Prolyx equipment and getting ready to board the press bus for McCain's next stop, the GOP Lincoln Day Dinner in Saginaw, the network techs listened to this reporter's summary of the press release and Murphy's comments and confirmed that the shrub has indeed gone negative. Be advised that these network camera and sound guys, who all have worked countless campaigns and who have neither the raging egos of journalists nor the self-interested agenda of the McCain 2000 staff to muddy their perspective, turn out to be way more acute and sensible political analysts than anyone you'll read or see on TV. And their assessment of today's negativity developments is so extraordinarily nuanced and sophisticated that only a small portion of it can be ripped off and summarized here. And the techs now kill the last of the time in the riverfront by coolly analyzing Bush's negativity and McCain's response from a tactical point of view.
在检查Prolyx设备并准备登上新闻巴士前往麦凯恩的下一站——萨吉诺的共和党林肯日晚宴时，网络技术人员听取了这位记者对新闻稿和墨菲评论的总结，并证实布什确实采取了负面攻击。请注意，这些网络摄像和音响人员，他们处理过无数次竞选，既没有记者那种狂暴的自我，也没有麦凯恩2000员工为了混淆视听而怀有的自身议程，结果证明他们比你在电视上读到或看到的任何人都要敏锐和感性。他们对今天负面发展的评估非常微妙和复杂，这里只能摘录和总结一小部分。技术人员现在通过从战术角度冷静分析布什的负面和麦凯恩的反应，打发了河畔酒店剩下的时间。
Going negative is risky. Countless polls have shown that voters find negativity distasteful in the extreme. And if a candidate is perceived as going negative, it usually costs him. But of course, G. W. Bush is a creature of his campaign advisers. And these advisers are the best that $70 million and the full faith and credit of the GOP establishment can buy. And if Bush 2000 has gone negative, there must be solid political logic behind the move.
采取负面攻击是有风险的。无数民意调查显示，选民对负面攻击极度反感。如果一个候选人被认为采取了负面攻击，通常会付出代价。但当然，乔治·W·布什是他竞选顾问的产物。这些顾问是7000万美元和共和党建制派的全部信誉所能买到的最好的。如果布什2000采取了负面攻击，幕后肯定有扎实的政治逻辑。
Under the techs' lens, this logic turns out to be indeed solid, even brilliant. The shrub's attack leaves McCain with two options. If he chooses not to retaliate, some South Carolina voters will credit McCain for taking the high road. But it could also come off as wimpy and might compromise McCain's image as a tough, take-no-[BLEEP] guy with the balls to take on the Washington cleptocracy.
在技术人员的镜头下，这个逻辑确实扎实，甚至可以说精明。布什的攻击给麦凯恩留下了两个选择。如果他选择不报复，一些南卡罗来纳州选民会称赞麦凯恩采取了高标准。但这可能显得软弱，并可能损害麦凯恩作为强硬、不废话的人，敢于挑战华盛顿权贵的形象。
So McCain pretty much has to strike back, the techs agree. But this is extremely dangerous. For by retaliating negatively, McCain runs the risk of looking like just another ambitious, win-at-any-cost politician. When after all, so much time and effort and money has gone into casting him as the opposite of that. Plus, the CBS cameraman points out that an even bigger reason why McCain can't afford to let the shrub, quote, "Pull him down to his level," is that if Bush then turns around and retaliates against the retaliation, and so then McCain has to rre-retaliate against Bush's retaliation, and so on, then the whole GOP race could quickly degenerate into just the sort of boring, depressing, cynical, charge and counter charge contest that turns voters off and keeps them away from the polls.
所以技术人员一致认为，麦凯恩几乎必须反击。但这极其危险。因为采取负面报复，麦凯恩冒着看起来像另一个雄心勃勃、不择手段政客的风险。毕竟，人们投入了大量时间和金钱将他塑造成这种形象的反面。此外，CBS摄像师指出，麦凯恩不能允许布什“把他拉到自己的水平”的一个更大原因是：如果布什转而对报复进行反报复，麦凯恩又不得不对布什的反报复再次反报复，如此循环，那么整个共和党竞选可能很快沦为那种无聊、压抑、愤世嫉俗的指责与反指责竞赛，这会把选民拒之门外。
And the other techs agree that the really important tactical point here is that John S. McCain cannot afford to have voters get turned off since, after all, his whole strategy is based on exciting people and inspiring them and pulling more voters in, especially people who'd stopped voting because they'd gotten so disgusted and bored with all the negativity and bull-[BLEEP] of politics.
其他技术人员同意，这里真正重要的战术点是，约翰·S·麦凯恩负担不起选民被拒之门外的后果，毕竟他的整个战略是基于激励人们，鼓舞他们，吸引更多选民，特别是那些因为对政治的消极和废话感到恶心和厌烦而停止投票的人。
In other words, this reporter proposes to the techs, it's maybe actually in the shrub's own political self-interest to let the GOP primary race get ugly and negative and have voters get so bored and cynical and disgusted with the whole thing that they don't even bother to vote. Well, no, [BLEEP], Sherlock H., the ABC techs, in essence, respond. Good old Frank C. then explaining more patiently that, yes, if there's a low voter turn out, then the majority of the people who get off their ass and do vote will be the die-hard Republicans, meaning the Christian Right and the party faithful. And these are the groups that vote as they're told, the ones controlled by the GOP establishment, an establishment that's got $70 million and 100% of its own credibility invested in the shrub.
“换句话说，”这位记者向技术人员建议，“也许让共和党初选变得丑陋和负面，让选民对这一切感到厌烦、愤世嫉俗和恶心，以至于他们甚至懒得投票，这实际上符合布什自己的政治利益。”“嗯，废话，福尔摩斯，”ABC的技术人员回应道。老实人弗兰克·C耐心地解释说，是的，如果投票率低，那么起身去投票的大多数人将是死忠共和党人，意味着基督教右翼和党的忠诚派。而这些是听指挥投票的群体，由共和党建制派控制，而这个建制派投入了7000万美元和100%的自身信誉在布什身上。
CNN's Mark A. posits that this also explains why the amazingly life-like Al Gore, over in the Democratic race, has been so relentlessly negative and depressing in his attacks on Bill Bradley. Since Gore, like the shrub, has his party's establishment behind him with all its organization and money and the die hards who fall into line and vote as they're told. It's in Big Al's interest to draw as few voters as possible into the Democratic primaries. Because the lower the overall turnout, the more the establishment voters' ballots actually count.
CNN的马克·A断言，这也解释了为何民主党初选中令人惊叹的、像真人一样（暗示其实很生硬）的阿尔·戈尔，在对付比尔·布拉德利（Bill Bradley）的攻击中为何如此无情且令人沮丧。因为戈尔和布什一样，有党的建制派在背后支持，拥有所有的组织、金钱和那些听命行事的死忠分子。对戈尔来说，在民主党初选中吸引尽可能少的选民才符合他的利益。因为总投票率越低，建制派选民选票的权重就越大。
Which fact then, in turn, the CBS cameraman says, helps explain why, even though our elected representatives are always wringing their hands and making concerned noises about low voter turn-outs, nothing substantive ever gets done to make politics less ugly or depressing and to actually induce more people to vote. Our elected representatives are incumbents. And low turnouts favor incumbents for the same reason soft money does.
CBS摄像师说，这一事实反过来解释了为什么尽管我们的民选代表总是绞尽脑汁地对低投票率表示关切，却从未采取任何实质性措施使政治变得不那么丑陋或令人沮丧，从而真正诱使更多人去投票。我们的民选代表都是现任官员。而低投票率对现任者有利，原因和“软钱”（soft money）一样。
By this time, the techs are on the press bus. And since it's only a 10-minute ride to the Saginaw GOP dinner, they have their cameras down and boom sticks retracted, but all their gear still strapped on, which forces them to sit up uncomfortably straight and wince at bumps. And in the bus' mirrored ceiling, they look even more like sci-fi combat troops on their way to some alien beachhead.
此时，技术人员已经在新闻巴士上了。由于去萨吉诺共和党晚宴只有10分钟路程，他们放下了摄像机，收起了吊杆，但所有装备仍然挂在身上，这迫使他们极其不舒服地挺直坐着，每遇到颠簸就呲牙咧嘴。在巴士的镜面天花板上，他们看起来更像是前往外星滩头的科幻作战部队。
In their opinion, tomorrow's response ad is not a promising start for McCain, especially the "Twist the truth like Clinton" line that the 12 monkeys jumped on Murphy for. This lines too mean. It does not sound high road. It sounds pissed off, aggressive, and it will allow Bush to do a react and now say that it's McCain who has violated the handshake agreement, which the techs say will, of course, be bull-[BLEEP] but that it might be effective bull-[BLEEP]. And that it's McCain's aggressive ad that's giving the shrub the opening to do it.
在他们看来，明天的响应广告对麦凯恩来说并不是一个好的开始，尤其是“像克林顿一样扭曲事实”那一句，这是“12只猴子”抓着墨菲不放的把柄。这句台词太刻薄了。听起来不像高标准，而像是愤怒、咄咄逼人，这会让布什做出反应，现在可以说违背握手协议的是麦凯恩。技术人员说，这当然是废话，但可能是有效的废话。而正是麦凯恩咄咄逼人的广告给了布什这样做的机会。
The tech's basic analysis of the motivation behind the ad's "Twist the truth like Clinton," line is that McCain is genuinely, personally pissed off at the shrub and that he has taken Mike Murphy's leash off and let Murphy do what Murphy does best which is gutter fight. McCain, after all, is known for having a temper. And Jim C. thinks that maybe the truly ingenious thing the shrub's strategists did was to find a way to genuinely piss McCain off and make him want to go negative, even though his staff had to have warned him that this was playing right into Bush's strategists hands.
技术人员对广告中“像克林顿一样扭曲事实”这一行背后的动机的基本分析是，麦凯恩本人真心对布什感到愤怒，他松开了迈克·墨菲的缰绳，让墨菲做他最擅长的事，那就是阴沟里的斗争。毕竟，麦凯恩以脾气暴躁著称。吉姆·C认为，也许布什战略家们真正天才的地方在于找到了一种方法，让麦凯恩真正感到愤怒，并想采取负面行动，即使他的员工肯定警告过他，这正中布什战略家下怀。
Jim's analysis suddenly reminds this reporter of the thing in The Godfather where Sonny Corleone's fatal flaw is his temper, which Barzini and Tattaglia exploit by getting Carlo to beat up Connie and makes Sonny so insanely angry that he drives off to kill Carlo and gets assassinated in Barzini's ambush at that tollbooth in the Richmond Parkway. And a taciturn but cinephilic CNN cameraman speculates that the Bush campaign's brain trust may actually have based their whole negative strategy on Barzini's ingenious ploy in The Godfather . Whereupon Frank C. observes that Bush's equivalent to slapping Connie Corleone around was standing up with a wacko vet who claimed that McCain dissed his Vietnam comrades, which at first might have looked stupid and unnecessarily nasty of Bush, but from another perspective might be sheer genius if it made McCain so angry that his desire to retaliate outweighed his political judgment.
吉姆的分析让这位记者突然想起了《教父》中桑尼·柯里昂（Sonny Corleone）的致命弱点是他的脾气，巴齐尼（Barzini）和塔塔利亚（Tattaglia）通过让卡洛（Carlo）殴打康妮（Connie）来利用这一点，使得桑尼疯狂愤怒，开车去杀卡洛，结果在里士满公园大道（Richmond Parkway）的收费站被伏击暗杀。一位沉默寡言但热爱电影的CNN摄像师推测，布什竞选团队的智囊团可能确实是基于巴齐尼在《教父》中的天才计谋来制定他们的整个负面战略的。于是弗兰克·C观察到，布什对待麦凯恩相当于殴打康妮·柯里昂的手段，就是与那位声称麦凯恩鄙视越南战友的疯子退伍军人站在一起，这起初看起来很愚蠢，且布什做得毫无必要地恶心，但从另一个角度看，如果这使麦凯恩如此愤怒，以至于他报复的愿望超过了他的政治判断力，那这可能就是天才之举。
Because, Frank C. warns, just watch. This retaliation, and Bush's response to it, and McCain's response to Bush's response-- this will be all that the 12 monkeys and the rest of the press corps are interested in. And if McCain lets things get too ugly, he won't be able to get anybody to pay attention to anything else.
因为，弗兰克·C警告说，看着吧。这种报复，以及布什对此的反应，以及麦凯恩对布什反应的反应——这将是“12只猴子”和其余新闻团唯一感兴趣的事情。如果麦凯恩让事情变得太丑陋，他就无法让任何人关注其他任何事情。
And sure enough, events of the next few days bear out the techs' analysis pretty much 100%. On Tuesday morning on the Radisson's TV in North Savannah, South Carolina, both Today and Good Morning America lead with, "The GOP campaign takes an ugly turn," and show the part of McCain's new ad where he says, "Twist the truth like Clinton."
果然，接下来几天的事件几乎百分之百印证了技术人员的分析。周二早上，在南卡罗来纳州北萨凡纳的雷迪森酒店电视上，《今日》（Today）和《早安美国》（Good Morning America）都以“共和党竞选出现丑陋转折”为头条，并播放了麦凯恩新广告中他说“像克林顿一样扭曲事实”的部分。
And sure enough, by midday the shrub has put out a react where he accuses John S. McCain of violating the handshake agreement and going negative and adds that he, the shrub, is personally offended and outraged at being compared to W. J. Clinton. And by Wednesday night, focus polls are showing that South Carolina voters are finding McCain's ad negative and depressing. And the next couple days' polls then have both McCain's support and the primaries projected voter turnout falling like a rock. And the daily press are having to turn out piece after piece about all the endless picayune charges and countercharges. And everyone on the bus is starting to get severely dispirited and bored. And even the 12 monkeys' strides have lost a certain smug spring.
果然，到中午时分，布什已经做出了反应，指责约翰·S·麦凯恩违背握手协议并采取负面攻击，并补充说，他本人对被比作W·J·克林顿感到被冒犯和愤怒。到周三晚上，重点民调显示南卡罗来纳州选民认为麦凯恩的广告负面且令人沮丧。随后的几天民调显示，麦凯恩的支持率和初选预计投票率像石头一样下跌。日报必须不断刊登关于那些无穷无尽、琐碎的指控与反指控的文章。巴士上的每个人都开始变得极其沮丧和厌烦。连“12只猴子”的步伐都失去了那种自鸣得意的活力。
And McCain not only, of course, loses South Carolina, but then a couple weeks later the whole Carlo and Sonny scenario plays out again on super Tuesday, only bigger this time with McCain lashing angrily out at the Christian Right and calling Robertson and Falwell agents of intolerance and basically alienating the whole GOP's die hard right-wing. And why? Because some person or persons unknown had gotten Falwell and Robertson to tape certain anti-McCain remarks and disseminate them via automated phone call to registered voters in key states, remarks so off-the-charts mean and distorted that they pissed McCain off enough that he goes on TV and gives the Christian Right the public finger. While Murphy and the McCain 2000 high command doubtless stand there and bite their wrists in frustration, practically seeing McCain's glossy coupe pull angrily up to that tollbooth.
而麦凯恩不仅在南卡罗来纳州失败，几周后，整个卡洛和桑尼的情节在“超级星期二”（Super Tuesday）再次上演，只是这次规模更大。麦凯恩愤怒地抨击基督教右翼，称罗伯逊（Robertson）和法尔韦尔（Falwell）是“不宽容的代理人”，基本上疏远了整个共和党的右翼死忠。为什么？因为某些不知名的人让法尔韦尔和罗伯逊录制了某些反麦凯恩的言论，并通过自动电话传播给关键州的登记选民，言论如此极端且扭曲，以至于让麦凯恩愤怒到上电视对基督教右翼公然竖中指。而墨菲和麦凯恩2000竞选指挥部无疑站在那里咬牙切齿地感到沮丧，几乎看着麦凯恩那辆闪亮的车愤怒地驶向那个收费站。
David Foster Wallace is the author of several books, including Brief Interviews with Hideous Men . This was an edited excerpt of a story that first appeared in Rolling Stone Magazine.
大卫·福斯特·华莱士是几本书的作者，包括《与丑陋男人的简短访谈》（Brief Interviews with Hideous Men）。这是故事的编辑节选，该故事首次出现在《滚石》杂志上。
Coming up, how to run a smear campaign in junior high school and how not to run one in a presidential race. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如何在初中进行抹黑竞选，以及如何在总统竞选中不进行抹黑。广告后回来，来自国际公共广播电台（PRI）。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- "Character Assassination," true stories to prepare us for the coming battle between George Bush and Al Gore. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, "When Slime is Good."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们每周都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同的故事。今天的主题是——“人格暗杀”，为我们即将到来的乔治·布什和阿尔·戈尔之间的战斗做好准备。我们已经进入节目的第三幕。第三幕，“当污蔑有益时”。
Ron Susskind's an author who's been on our show. But years ago he was a political consultant. He says that when he began in politics, he thought there was nothing lower than negative campaigning. And then, in 1980, he learned that sometimes when your opponent attacks, it can actually help you. At the time he was working on John Anderson's campaign for president, Anderson was being attacked by candidate Ronald Reagan and by candidate Jimmy Carter.
罗恩·萨斯金德（Ron Susskind）是曾经在我们节目中出现过的一位作家。但多年前，他是一位政治顾问。他说，当他刚开始涉足政治时，他认为没有什么比负面竞选更低级的了。后来，在1980年，他了解到，有时当对手攻击你时，这实际上会帮助你。当时他正在为约翰·安德森（John Anderson）的竞选团队工作，安德森当时受到了候选人罗纳德·里根（Ronald Reagan）和吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）的攻击。
The Democrats would say, he's Don Quixote. He's flaky. He's on an ether binge. I mean, they just went after him. And on the Republican side, Anderson is a liberal and is controlled by his wife. That was a big thing that came out.
“民主党人会说，他是堂吉诃德。他是个怪胎。他在吸食乙醚。我的意思是，他们就是攻击他。而在共和党方面，安德森是个自由派，受他妻子的控制。这成了当时传出来的一件大事。”
And the more they attacked, what did it do to Anderson's popularity?
“随着他们攻击得越多，这对安德森的受欢迎程度有什么影响？”
Well, that was the interesting part. The more they attacked, the better it was for us. His poll ratings rose steadily through the summer. Steadily and swiftly. He almost seemed to feel their focus and intensity on him, by virtue of their attack, and say see, they do care about me. They are worried about me. They are attacking me just to prove that. And it doesn't bother me one little bit.
“嗯，那是有趣的部分。他们攻击得越多，对我们越有利。他的民调支持率在整个夏天稳步上升。稳步而迅速。他似乎通过他们的攻击，感受到了他们对他的关注和强度，仿佛在说：看，他们确实在乎我。他们担心我。他们攻击我正是为了证明这一点。这对我一点影响都没有。”
That's interesting. Because as a third party candidate, his big problem was that people might not take him seriously as a threat. And here he's got the two other candidates letting people know he is a threat.
“真有意思。因为作为第三方候选人，他的大问题是人们可能不把他当作威胁来看待。而现在，其他两位候选人让人们知道他是一个威胁。”
Exactly, by virtue of their focus on him.
“确实，正因为他们对他的关注。”
Do the attacks do anything else, in terms of people's feeling about a candidate?
“攻击在人们对候选人的感受方面还有其他作用吗？”
Yeah, they do. They do. They provide opportunities where the candidate must be real and genuine and show his or her self to the public. They break through the noise of the canned stuff. And when the attacks come, people sort of snap to attention. Because they figure whether or not the attack is credible, what I'll see now is I'll see candidate X actually respond like a real person, like I would. And it allows for that window, that moment for the voter to actually see the face of something real.
“有的，有的。它们提供了机会，候选人必须真实、真诚，向公众展示自己。它们打破了那些冠冕堂皇的噪音。当攻击到来时，人们会变得专注。因为他们想，无论攻击是否可信，现在我看到的将是候选人X像一个真正的人那样做出回应，就像我会做的那样。这提供了一个窗口，一个让选民真正看到真实事物的机会。”
Ron Susskind in Washington, D. C.
罗恩·萨斯金德在华盛顿特区。
Act Four. "Who You Gonna Call?" Character assassination, you know, runs all through our society. And there is an entire class of consultant who does nothing but help people and companies that are under public attack. Eric Dezenhall is one of these people. He works for a crisis management firm in Washington, D. C.
第四幕，“你该打给谁？”你知道，“人格暗杀”贯穿于我们的整个社会。有一整类顾问只做一件事，就是帮助那些受到公众攻击的人和公司。埃里克·德森霍尔（Eric Dezenhall）就是其中之一。他在华盛顿特区一家危机管理公司工作。
What is very important for people to understand is that character assassination has become big business. There are a series of folks who package attacks. And they include plaintiffs' lawyers, activist groups, individuals with random axe to grind and who are willing to get on TV and say something bad about either a product or a person. And the media are very, very likely to embrace these attacks. There is a huge infrastructure and distribution channel by which to sell it. For example, when Kathie Lee Gifford was attacked by the magazine, The Globe , where her husband was set up in a hotel room with a stewardess, if that's what you'd like to call her.
“人们必须明白，人格暗杀已经成为一门大生意。有一群人专门打包攻击方案。其中包括原告律师、激进组织、随机找茬的人，他们愿意上电视说某个产品或人的坏话。而媒体非常、非常乐于接受这些攻击。有一个庞大的基础设施和分发渠道来兜售它。例如，当凯西·李·吉福德（Kathie Lee Gifford）遭到《环球报》（The Globe）的攻击，她的丈夫被安排在酒店房间里和一位空姐在一起时——如果你想这么称呼她的话。”
A stewardess who was paid by The Globe.
“一位被《环球报》收买的空姐。”
A stewardess who was paid. The very same people who claimed they were disgusted by this type of thing drove up The Globe's sales by 15% that year.
“一位被收买的空姐。正是那些声称对这种事情感到反感的人，在那一年将《环球报》的销量推高了15%。”
It's interesting to me. One of the things that you argue is that one reason why these kinds of things happen a lot is that we want somebody to be the villain. You write about filling the villain void. And that there's something in us where we want to see somebody brought down.
“这对我来说很有趣。你认为这类事情频繁发生的一个原因是，我们希望某个人成为反派。你写到了‘填补反派真空’。你认为我们内心有一种想要看到某个人被拉下马的欲望。”
Yeah. The attack on Kathie Lee Gifford was, of course, engineered by finding a vulnerability with her husband. But there's no question that the target was Kathie Lee Gifford. People were out to get her for a long, long time. And my feeling is, when you get on television day after day and you talk about your perfect marriage and your perfect children, you have a lot of people out there who are saying, I don't have a perfect marriage. I don't have perfect children. Enough with her already. And the public was extremely receptive to any negative information they got from her, about her.
“是的。对凯西·李·吉福德的攻击当然是通过寻找她丈夫的弱点来策划的。但毫无疑问，目标是凯西·李·吉福德。长期以来，人们一直想搞垮她。我的感觉是，当你每天上电视谈论你完美的婚姻和完美的子女时，外面的很多人会说：‘我没有完美的婚姻。我没有完美的子女。受够她了。’公众对任何来自她的、关于她的负面信息都极其敏感。”
Can we just talk about the strategy used by Kathie Lee Gifford and her husband, Frank, once this news came out? The fact that they let people know that they were hurt, that this hurt their marriage, that this caused them pain, how important is that?
“我们可以谈谈凯西·李·吉福德和她丈夫弗兰克（Frank）在消息传出后采取的策略吗？他们让人们知道他们很受伤，这伤害了他们的婚姻，这让他们痛苦，这有多重要？”
I think the first thing that the Gifford's did, as I recall it, was incorrect, which is to deny that this had happened. Ultimately though, they found out a little uncomfortable fact which is, there was film.
“我想吉福德夫妇最初做的第一件事，据我回忆，是不正确的，那就是否认这件事的发生。但最终，他们发现了一个令人不舒服的事实，那就是：有录像。”
That's right. The Globe staged it very cunningly. First they released the news, and then they got the denials. And then they came out with the video the week later.
“没错。《环球报》非常狡猾地策划了这一切。首先他们发布了新闻，然后得到了否认。接着一周后，他们拿出了录像。”
Well, that's exactly right. Initially, they denied it. And when there's hard core evidence-- no pun intended-- it's a very, very hard thing to back out from. But the next thing that the Giffords did was absolutely correct. They acknowledged what the most fundamental thing that the public wanted to hear was, which was that they are human and that they are hurt. And one way to get people off your back is to concede that you're human. And that is really what, a lot of times, the goal of these attacks are, to bring you down to our size.
“嗯，确实如此。起初，他们否认了。当有确凿证据时——不是双关语——这很难退出。但吉福德夫妇接下来的举动是绝对正确的。他们承认了公众最想听到的最基本的事情，那就是他们是人，他们也会受伤。让人不再找你麻烦的一种方法是承认你是人。而这往往就是这些攻击的目标：把你们拉到和我们一样的高度。”
I think that the media understand that there are certain basic things in human nature where the narratives have to be repeated. And the public enjoys seeing someone who they believe has too much fall.
“我认为媒体明白，人性中存在某些基本的东西，叙事必须被重复。公众喜欢看到他们认为拥有太多的人跌倒。”
One of the things that's striking about it is, when the attack comes, they are cast as characters in this drama. And at that point, it's almost as if they have to choose what role they want to play and have to give people the satisfaction people would get from a drama. That is, people want to see them take a fall. They have to be contrite. If they're defiant, they won't be playing the character that will actually end the story.
“其中一点令人震惊的是，当攻击到来时，他们被塑造成了这场戏剧中的角色。在那一刻，几乎就像他们必须选择自己想扮演的角色，并必须给人们他们能从戏剧中获得的满足感。也就是说，人们想看到他们跌倒。他们必须忏悔。如果他们反抗，他们就不会扮演那个真正能结束故事的角色。”
Every news attack is packaged like a traditional Hollywood entertainment. There is a villain. There is a victim. There is a vindicator. And you can either be the villain, the victim, or the vindicator. In this particular case, the Giffords were the villains. They were people who lied to us about the quality of their marriage. The victims, of course, were us, the American public, who were duped by these horrible people. And the vindicator, of course, was The Globe , who came forward to bring this truth, this hideous truth, to us. The Giffords have a choice at that moment. They can either stay the villains or they can become the victims. And neither is a wonderful choice, by the way. And the best choice for them at that point was to come forward and show their humanity by playing the role of the victim.
“每一条新闻攻击都被包装成传统的好莱坞娱乐节目。有一个反派，一个受害者，一个辩护者。你可以选择做反派、受害者或辩护者。在这个特定案例中，吉福德夫妇是反派。他们是对我们撒谎说婚姻质量好的人。受害者当然是我们，被这些可怕的人愚弄的美国公众。而辩护者当然是《环球报》，他们挺身而出，带给我们这个真相，这个可怕的真相。吉福德夫妇在那一刻有选择。他们要么继续做反派，要么成为受害者。顺便说一句，这都不是什么好的选择。对于他们来说，当时最好的选择是挺身而出，通过扮演受害者的角色来展现他们的人性。”
The thing about an attack is that it must end with a clear and unequivocal conclusion or the public is frustrated. We want total guilt. We want total innocence. The conclusions have to be unequivocal.
“关于攻击的一点是，它必须以明确且毫无疑问的结论结束，否则公众会感到沮丧。我们想要完全的罪恶感，我们想要完全的清白。结论必须是毫不含糊的。”
What would you advise somebody like Governor Bush to do about the attacks on his record and tenure that are happening now? For example, the vice president is saying that Governor Bush isn't ready for office, that his tax plan and his foreign policy plans are risky, that Texas-- his record in Texas-- is terrible because Texas has substandard health and education policies. The vice president calls Texas the most polluted state in the country. What should George Bush do against that? What are his options?
“你会建议像布什州长这样的人对目前发生的针对他记录和任期的攻击做什么？例如，副总统说布什州长还没有准备好担任公职，他的税收计划和外交政策计划风险很大，德克萨斯州——他在德克萨斯州的记录——很糟糕，因为德克萨斯州有不达标的医疗和教育政策。副总统称德克萨斯州是全国污染最严重的州。乔治·布什应该如何对抗这些？他的选择是什么？”
In order for an attack to work, it doesn't have to be true. It has to be plausible and resonant. And the first thing he has to do is find out which of these attacks is resonating. I think that the biggest attack on Bush that does resonate is this broad notion-- not of this policy or that policy-- but that he is not a guy who has the seasoning to handle this job. And the best thing he can do is demonstrate that he does. And one of the ways to do that, unfortunately, is to go on the attack back against Gore.
“为了让攻击生效，它不必是真的。它必须是合理的和有共鸣的。他要做的第一件事就是找出这些攻击中哪些产生了共鸣。我认为布什面临的最大攻击点在于这种广泛的观念——不是针对这个或那个政策——而是他不是一个有足够阅历来处理这项工作的人。他能做的最好的事情就是证明他有。而不幸的是，做到这一点的方法之一就是反过来攻击戈尔。”
Now, if your follow-up question is, are you saying that he should defend by, in effect, attacking-- unfortunately, that is what I'm saying. Whoever attacks wins the market. Whoever attacks gets to the news cycle most quickly. And I think that his best overall response is going to be continuing to attack Gore. And one of the reasons why I think that this campaign is going to be intensely negative is because neither of these guys is likable and can skate on their charm.
“现在，如果你的后续问题是，你是说他应该通过攻击来防御吗？不幸的是，这就是我要说的。谁发起攻击，谁就赢得了市场。谁发起攻击，谁就最快进入新闻周期。我认为他最好的整体回应将是继续攻击戈尔。我认为这次竞选将极其负面，原因之一是这两个人都不讨人喜欢，无法靠魅力混过去。”
Is it possible, when attacked, to respond simply with the truth? Or is it always better to respond with another attack, a counterattack?
“当受到攻击时，只用真相来回应可能吗？还是用另一次攻击、一次反击来回应总是更好？”
I am not speaking as a moralist. I am speaking as a clinician. And as a clinician, I can tell you that I do not see clients that have been immediately forgiven for confessing certain things. Morally, I think that is disquieting. But in terms of reality, as I look over my clients over two decades, I have not seen a correlation in my career between confession and forgiveness.
“我不是以道德家身份说话。我是以临床医生身份说话。作为临床医生，我可以告诉你，我没有看到客户因为承认某些事情而立即被原谅。在道德上，我认为这令人不安。但在现实层面，当我回顾过去二十年我的客户时，我的职业生涯中并没有发现忏悔与宽恕之间的相关性。”
Hm. Eric, do you feel like there's something Pollyanna-ish about even wanting to get the attacks out of politics? That is, do you feel like, in fact, in a deeper way there's nothing wrong with these attacks in politics?
“嗯。埃里克，你觉得甚至想要将攻击从政治中剔除的想法是否有点过于天真？也就是说，你是否觉得，实际上在更深层次上，这些政治攻击并没有什么错？”
Well, I don't think that all of these attacks are nearly as destructive and as new as the public likes. I just think, at some level, attacking does ferret out the truth. The problem, in my view, is differentiating between attacks that are a part of debate and attacks that are just plain smears.
“嗯，我不认为所有这些攻击都像公众喜欢的那样具有破坏性和新鲜感。我只是认为，在某种程度上，攻击确实能挖掘出真相。在我看来，问题在于区分作为辩论一部分的攻击和仅仅是污蔑的攻击。”
But in the case of politics, it seems like the kind of smears that one sees are things that-- they have an element of truth, but how much truth they have is open to debate. For example, George Bush saying about Vice President Gore, "He'll say anything to get elected." Well, there certainly is an element of truth in that. And we all have seen that. And the same thing on the converse. You know, the vice president saying about George Bush, "He isn't seasoned." Well, he isn't seasoned when it comes to all these kinds of policies.
“但在政治案例中，看起来人们看到的污蔑——它们包含一部分真相，但其中有多少真相是有争议的。例如，乔治·布什说副总统戈尔，‘他会为了当选而说任何话。’嗯，这当然有一部分真相。我们都看到了。反之亦然。你知道，副总统说乔治·布什，‘他没经验。’嗯，当涉及到所有这些政策时，他确实没经验。”
Yeah, I think that these are examples of attacks that are legitimate. The fact is-- these so-called attacks are really a part of a broader debate that get to certain critical questions. Look, I believe that even the questions about Bush's alleged drug use are germane. Because I believe that one of the things that is nagging at a lot of the country-- and this was true of John F. Kennedy as well-- is, is it a healthy thing to have a rich kid who has never had a tough day in his life sitting in the oval office? Whether or not the allegations, one by one, are true isn't as important as the fact that the broader questions are being asked. And frankly, I don't think it's the most unhealthy thing in the world.
“是的，我认为这些是合法攻击的例子。事实是——这些所谓的攻击实际上是更广泛辩论的一部分，涉及某些关键问题。看，我相信即使关于布什所谓吸毒的问题也是切题的。因为我相信，让整个国家感到困扰的一件事——这也适用于约翰·F·肯尼迪——是，让一个一生中从未经历过艰难日子的富家子弟坐在椭圆形办公室里，是一件健康的事情吗？这些指控是否逐一属实并不重要，重要的是更广泛的问题被提出来了。老实说，我不认为这是世界上最不健康的事情。”
Eric Dezenhall of the Nichols-Dezenhall Communications Management Group. He's the author of a book about his craft called, Nail 'Em.
埃里克·德森霍尔，来自尼科尔斯-德森霍尔传播管理集团（Nichols-Dezenhall Communications Management Group）。他写了一本关于他手艺的书，书名叫《钉住他们》（Nail 'Em）。
[MUSIC- "WASHINGTON, D.C." BY THE MAGNETIC FIELDS]
[音乐 - 磁场乐队（The Magnetic Fields）《华盛顿特区》]
Act Five, "When Attacks Really Count." Though Washington, D. C., you think that's mean? Just remember junior high school. That's when character assassination really hurt. We have this story.
第五幕，“当攻击真正起作用时”。虽然华盛顿特区，你觉得那很刻薄？记住初中。那是人格暗杀真正伤害人的时候。我们有这个故事。
I guess this is about Dave and me, right? Dave and I became friends in fourth grade. And we were friends through sixth grade. And I have to describe him physically, because that's a huge part of his personality. He was, and he still is, an extremely wiry person. Very thin. He looks emaciated. And he also-- his skin is like a jaundiced yellow color. He was always very acned and he just looked sick all the time. He was a very meek, quiet kid, very un-assuming. Nobody ever really noticed him doing anything.
“我想这是关于我和戴夫（Dave）的，对吧？我和戴夫在四年级成了朋友。我们一直友好到六年级。我必须从身体上描述他，因为那是他个性中很大的一部分。他过去是，现在仍然是一个极其瘦削的人。非常瘦。他看起来营养不良。而且他的皮肤像黄疸病一样的黄色。他总是长满痤疮，看起来总是病恹恹的。他是一个非常温顺、安静的孩子，非常低调。没人真正注意到他做过什么。”
I don't really know how we became friends. We were in class together in grade school. And our favorite group was the Village People. And we used to listen to the Village People all the time and just totally obsess about them. And The Dukes of Hazzard was another one, and Star Wars . Those were very big things.
“我真的不知道我们是怎么成为朋友的。我们在小学同班。我们最喜欢的组合是乡村人乐队（Village People）。我们过去常听乡村人乐队的歌，完全痴迷于他们。《哈扎德公爵》（The Dukes of Hazzard）是另一个，还有《星球大战》（Star Wars）。那些都是非常重要的东西。”
And as things progressed into fifth grade, it became pretty clear that our friendship was the most intense friendship in the class. Teachers started separating us in the classrooms constantly, like on the first day of school. They wouldn't even think about it. We would talk on the phone at least once a day and for hours. We would just talk for hours.
“随着五年级的推进，很明显我们的友谊是班上最浓厚的。老师开始不断地把我们在教室里分开，就像开学第一天一样。他们甚至不想。我们每天至少通话一次，而且一聊就是几个小时。我们只是聊了几个小时。”
I basically discovered sexuality through him. And we used to-- I remember the first thing that we did together that was sexual was we went into his parents' bedroom. And we got the J. C. Penney catalog and looked through it and went to the bra and panties section and looked through this. And it was the first time I had ever indulged in this. I always kind of skipped it over.
“我基本上是通过他发现了性。而且我们过去常——我记得我们在一起做的第一件有性意味的事是，我们溜进他父母的卧室。我们拿了J.C. Penney的目录，翻到了内衣部分，看着那个。这是我第一次沉迷于此。我总是跳过它。”
And then the other thing that we did was we used to play Spin the Bottle in his room. And we would take off an article of clothing for when it would land on us. And it was the first time we'd ever been naked in front of another person except for our parents. And it was petrifying. But it was also just this whole discovery period of just seeing another man naked there.
“然后我们做的另一件事是我们在他房间里玩转瓶子。当我们被抽到时，我们就会脱掉一件衣服。这是我们第一次在父母之外的另一个人面前赤身裸体。这很吓人。但这也只是那种发现期，看到另一个男人赤身裸体在那里。”
And it became this whole game that we played often. And we just would revel in the fact of just standing there in front of each other, totally naked, assuming these characters just like-- hi, Mr. Jones, how are you? Nice to meet you. Businessmen and everything, just standing there completely buck naked and so terrified that we were ever going to get caught. Because his parents were always home. They were always in the house and everything and we were just so afraid that someone was going to knock on the door.
“它成了我们经常玩的一个游戏。我们只是沉浸在这样一个事实中：彼此面前赤身裸体，扮演这些角色，就像——你好，琼斯先生，你好吗？很高兴见到你。商人们什么的，只是赤身裸体地站在那里，非常害怕被抓到。因为他的父母总是在家。他们总是在房子里什么的，我们非常害怕有人会敲门。”
The point that it started to change was as we were going into sixth grade. And that's around the time when people start to-- people in sixth grade start to realize that there's a difference between someone who's straight and someone who's gay. And there was just rumblings happening. People were accusing us of being homosexual. We weren't in any way. But we also knew of all the things that we had done with each other, in each other's presence. And "faggot" was like the most derogatory thing you could call somebody. And people were thinking these things.
“开始改变的时刻是我们升入六年级的时候。那大约是人们开始——六年级的人开始意识到直男和同性恋者之间有区别的时候。当时有一些传言。人们指责我们是同性恋。我们根本不是。但我们也知道我们曾在彼此面前做的所有事情。而‘基佬’（faggot）就像是你能称呼某人的最侮辱性的东西。人们在想这些事情。”
I think when people started to think that we were gay, we suddenly realized that there was a cool thing and a not cool thing. And we were definitely not cool in the friendship that we were in. And that's also around that time when-- in my town at least, and I think in a lot of small towns-- when sports just become the most important thing in your life. And I was not a good athlete then at all. Dave was a good athlete. And Dave organized a big football party one weekend where we were going to go out there and play football and have a sleepover and then the next day play more football.
“我想当人们开始认为我们是同性恋时，我们突然意识到有一件酷事和一件不酷的事。而我们所在的友谊绝对是不酷的。那大约也是在那个时候——至少在我的城镇，我想在很多小城镇——运动成为你生命中最重要的事情。我当时根本不是个好运动员。戴夫是个好运动员。戴夫在一个周末组织了一个大型橄榄球派对，我们要去那里踢球，来个留宿，第二天再踢更多的球。”
Dave just organized this thing unbelievably. He had jerseys printed up with numbers and names on them. He had teams with rosters. He had practice for his team with plays. There was like a playbook. This is for a little football game like three-on-three football or four-on-four football. And every single minute was decided upon beforehand by him as to what we would do-- where we would be, what we would eat, the food we would eat, when we would play football. It was all timed out. He's just so organized and anal retentive about it.
“戴夫简直令人难以置信地组织了这件事。他印了带有号码和名字的球衣。他有带有花名册的球队。他为他的球队带了战术练习。就像有一本战术手册。这只是一场小橄榄球赛，像三对三或者四对四的橄榄球。每一分钟都是他预先决定好的——我们要去哪里，我们要吃什么，我们要吃的食物，什么时候踢橄榄球。一切都按时间安排好了。他在这方面非常细致且强迫症。”
And so when we got out there and played, I don't remember very well, but I can't imagine that I played tremendously well. And there were other really good athletes there. And I was horrible. And I think-- I was thinking about this today. I was trying to think of the moment when everything changed. And I'm almost positive it was that event. It was the football party. And immediately after that, he just totally stopped talking to me.
“所以当我们出去玩的时候，我记得不太清楚，但我无法想象我玩得很好。那里还有其他非常优秀的运动员。而我糟透了。我想——我今天在想这个。我试图想出一切改变的时刻。我几乎可以肯定就是那次事件。就是橄榄球派对。在那之后，他立刻完全停止跟我说话了。”
I remember going into class in seventh grade on the first day of school and him not talking to me and everybody just wondering. I mean, the whole school was wondering why there was this big fight going on between Dave and Bob. And I remember just not having an answer for anybody. I used to tell them to ask Dave. I had no idea. And I remember that, all of a sudden, he just was completely bent on turning everyone against me, the whole school. And he did it very well.
“我记得七年级开学第一天走进教室，他不跟我说话，每个人都在纳闷。我的意思是，全校都在纳闷为什么戴夫和鲍勃之间发生了这场大战。我记得我没法给任何人回答。我过去常告诉他们去问戴夫。我根本不知道。我记得，突然之间，他完全执着于让每个人都反对我，全校。他做得非常好。”
He was the one who formed the "I hate--" they used to call me Cooz then-- and he was the one who formed the "I hate Cooz" club. He never did anything to me himself. He would never come up to me and make fun of me. He would never come up to me and hit me. But he would just get everyone else to do it for him. I remember one time in the lunchroom, Sam saying, have you ever been caught masturbating?
“是他组建了‘我恨——’他们当时叫我库兹（Cooz）——是他组建了‘我恨库兹’俱乐部。他从没对我做过什么。他从不会走到我面前取笑我。他从不会走到我面前打我。但他会让其他人为他做。我记得有一次在餐厅，萨姆（Sam）说：‘你有没有被抓到自慰过？’”
And of course, either answer is-- you damn yourself if you answer yes or if you answer no. And I remembered hearing Dave tell him to ask me that. He was just able to organize people into these different factions. He was able to shift their focus really well. But from a really guarded position far away. He would just say, go over to Cooz and just shove him into a locker. And they'd go do it. People would make fun of the way that I chewed at lunch. People would make fun of the way that I laughed. People would make fun of the way that I coughed, that I sneezed. But that makes it even sound less violent than it was. It was just a mocking. It was a very pointed mocking on everyone's part.
“当然，无论回答是——如果你回答是或不是，你都在诅咒自己。我记得听到戴夫叫他那样问我。他能够把人组织成这些不同的派别。他能很好地转移他们的注意力。但从一个很远的被保护的位置。他只会说：‘去库兹那边，把他推到储物柜里。’他们就会去做。人们会取笑我在午餐时的咀嚼方式。人们会取笑我的笑声。人们会取笑我咳嗽、打喷嚏的方式。但这让它听起来比实际还要温和。那只是一种嘲弄。那是每个人都针对的嘲弄。”
I remember sitting alone at the lunch table with no one to talk to and just wanting so badly for no one to turn their attention to me because I knew that the attention would be negative. I remember just not understanding what was going on. I had been in such a sweet position with this person. We had such a good friendship and then all of a sudden everyone had just turned against me.
“我记得独自坐在午餐桌旁，没人和我说话，我非常渴望没人把注意力转向我，因为我知道那注意力会是负面的。我记得只是不明白发生了什么。我曾在这个人面前处于如此甜蜜的位置。我们曾有过如此美好的友谊，然后突然间每个人都反对我了。”
That was the worst period, I think, of my entire life, was that period. I used to go home from school and cry after school. I used to go to my dog and hug my dog and say, you are my only friend in the world.
“那是我一生中最糟糕的时期。我过去常在放学回家后哭泣。我过去常走到我的狗身边，抱住它说：‘你是世界上我唯一的朋友。’”
I remember one thing that he did was-- there was this guy, Mike, in my class. And Mike was, what we called in my hometown, a scummer, which meant that he was on welfare. He perhaps didn't have a pair of pants for every day of the week. He was very smart, which was a strike against him at that age. And he just didn't fit in. He was a real geek.
“我记得他做过的一件事是——班上有个家伙叫迈克（Mike）。迈克就是我们家乡所说的‘穷渣’（scummer），意思是他靠福利生活。他可能不是每周的每一天都有裤子穿。他很聪明，在那个年龄是个减分项。他就是不合群。他是个十足的怪胎。”
And so Dave organized this fight between Mike and I, a fist fight to prove who was the bigger faggot. Whoever would lose was the bigger faggot. And he positioned us, he spun it so there was no way I could not fight. If I didn't have this fight, then things would just get worse for me. Things would get worse. Mike was at the bottom of the barrel. And I was there with him. And Dave had to prove that I was below him. And so he organized this whole fight. And everyone in the class was like, are you going to fight Mike? Are you going to fight Mike? And I finally just conceded and I conceded to fight him.
“所以戴夫策划了我和迈克之间的一场战斗，一场拳击赛，来证明谁是更大的‘基佬’。谁输了，谁就是更大的‘基佬’。他安排了我们，他扭曲事实，使我无法不打。如果我不打这场架，事情只会对我更糟。事情会变得更糟。迈克在底层。我当时也在那儿。戴夫必须证明我在他之下。所以他策划了整场战斗。班上的每个人都在说：‘你要和迈克打架吗？你要和迈克打架吗？’我最终还是屈服了，我屈服于和他打架。”
And Dave organized the whole event. It was to happen at this playground. And we went. And he tried to get this whole audience to come and see it. Unfortunately, nobody came but him. Well, I guess, fortunately. Nobody came but him and one other person. So Mike and I went there. And neither of us wanted to fight each other. Neither of us had any reason in the world to fight each other. So I just remember standing there facing him just laughing, just like, what are we supposed to do?
“戴夫组织了整个活动。地点在操场。我们去了。他试图让整个观众群来看。不幸的是，除了他没人来。嗯，我想，幸运的是。除了他和另外一个人没人来。所以迈克和我去了那里。我们谁都不想打架。我们谁都没有理由打架。所以我只记得站在那里面对着他笑，就像，我们该怎么办？”
We're standing here. We've been forced into this just to save our own souls. And now we have to inflict pain on each other. And we stood there for the longest time and Dave kept trying to push us into fighting. He was saying, come on, just throw a punch, just throw a punch. Just start.
“我们站在这里。我们被强迫进这里只是为了拯救自己的灵魂。现在我们必须互相伤害。我们站了很长时间，戴夫一直试图推我们打架。他说：‘来吧，挥一拳，挥一拳。开始吧。’”
And we waited for the longest time. And then finally, I was just like, this is ridiculous. So I went up and I shoved him. And then we started to fight. And we weren't really into fighting. But we had to do it then. And I pushed him at one point and he fell backwards and he hurt his wrist. And I got on top of him and I held his wrist. And I remember saying to him, do you give up? And he wouldn't give up. And I was holding his wrists back.
“我们等了很久。最后，我只是觉得：这太荒谬了。所以我走过去推了他。然后我们就开始打架了。我们并不是真的想打。但我们当时不得不这么做。有一次我推了他，他向后摔倒，弄伤了手腕。我压在他身上，抓住了他的手腕。我记得我对他说：‘你认输吗？’他不认输。我抓着他的手腕向后。
And each time, I kept asking him if he was going to give up. And he kept saying, no. And each time he'd say no I'd bend his wrist back a little bit more. And he was just crying in pain. And I kept saying, I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back. I'm going to bend it back, thinking, I don't want to break this person's wrist. I have no reason to break this person's wrist. And I was faced at that moment with either giving up and just getting kicked even more or going ahead with really hurting this person and hoping that it would save me in some way. And I broke his wrist.
“每次我问他是否认输，他都一直说不。每次他说不，我就把他的手腕再往后弯一点。他只是在痛苦地哭泣。我一直说：‘我要把它掰回去，我要把它掰回去，我要把它掰回去。’心想，我不想弄断这个人的手腕。我没有任何理由弄断这个人的手腕。那一刻我面临着要么放弃，被踢得更惨，要么继续真的伤害这个人，并希望这能以某种方式拯救我。我弄断了他的手腕。”
He came in the next day, into school, with a cast on. I don't know how his family paid for his cast. And everybody saw that and said, you idiot, Cooz, what did you do? You idiot. And they just-- it made it even worse for me. It just made it worse.
“第二天他带着石膏进学校了。我不知道他的家庭是怎么支付他石膏费用的。每个人都看到了，并说：‘你这白痴，库兹，你做了什么？你这白痴。’他们只是——这让我情况更糟。这只会让事情更糟。”
Dave, he had no reason for this. He didn't understand it himself, I don't think. It was a complete visceral reaction to an allegation of homosexuality, I think. And so he, in order to preserve himself, just pointed at someone else and said, they're the one. And everybody just turned with him.
“戴夫，他对此没有任何理由。我不认为他自己明白。我想这完全是对同性恋指控的一种内脏反应。所以他为了保护自己，只是指着别人说：‘他们才是那个。’每个人都跟着他转。”
And I think that people that age are looking for things like this. Those are grades where you are forming factions. You're forming groups. And the easiest way to be part of a group is to just point at somebody else, I think, and say, I'm not like him.
“我认为那个年龄的人在寻找这样的事情。那是你形成派别的年级。你正在形成群体。我想，成为群体一员最简单的方法就是指着别人说：‘我不像他。’”
I went to the Pennsylvania Governor's School for the Arts in my junior year, the summer between my junior and senior year. And I remember very clearly, there was a moment at Governor's school where I thought that the clouds just cleared and everything became possible. It was after lunch and we were going out of the cafeteria and I'd forgotten my bag in the cafeteria. And I went and I said, oh just wait for me one second. I just want to go get my bag. And I went down to the cafeteria and I got my bag. And I came back up and they were still there waiting for me. And I remember, so distinctly, remembering-- oh my god, these people, they waited for me. That meant so much to me because I felt like, there are people out there. And I'm not this idiot. I'm not this geek. I'm not a person who everyone should hate. I'm actually a pretty good human being and people like me.
“我在高三那年去了宾夕法尼亚州州长艺术学校，是在高二到高三的夏天。我记得非常清楚，在州长学校有一个时刻，我以为云雾散开，一切皆有可能。那是在午餐后，我们要走出食堂，我把包忘在食堂了。我说：‘等我一秒钟。我只是想去拿我的包。’我下楼到食堂拿了包。我回来时他们还在那里等我。我记得，非常清晰地记得——哦，天哪，这些人，他们等我。这对我很重要，因为我感觉，外面还有人。我不是这个白痴。我不是这个怪胎。我不是一个每个人都应该讨厌的人。我其实是一个相当好的人，人们喜欢我。”
Bob Cucuzza is now a filmmaker and does theatre in New York. He spoke with Paul Tough.
鲍勃·库库扎（Bob Cucuzza）现在是一位电影制作人，在纽约从事戏剧工作。他与保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）进行了交谈。
And then literally, within 24 hours of at least, of putting our name forward, we were hit with a withering attack.
“然后，字面上说，在提出我们的名字后至少24小时内，我们就遭到了毁灭性的攻击。”
Indeed you were. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
“确实如此。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。”
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。